Amerika so I couldn't go another day
without talking about New America in
American America we have a new and only
trailer for Captain America the Winter
Soldier not gonna lie it looks pretty
tasty you do anything funny Saturday
night well all the guys in my barbershop
quartet are dead no not really I love
the fact that Black Widow still and it
looks like everyone after the Avengers
disbanded they're doing their own things
now but Captain America is like I'm
gonna work with shield stone because I
would work with shield because shield is
ultimately like super homeland security
for America and I'm mr. Captain America
so America works with America for the
better American America no parachutes
though those are for [ __ ] you're too
scared is he wearing a parachute no yeah
I think captures died of course he
didn't die it's Captain Marvel I like
what they're showing us in this trailer
of Captain America the Winter Soldier
Captain America is an idealistic
old-school soldier no background
everyone was smoking cigarettes feels
like they don't give you cancer they're
awesome
truth justice America and there are
parades when wars in but now it's a
darker time it's like no you need to
stop people before they do bad [ __ ] you
stopped them by wasting them probably
we're gonna neutralize a lot of threats
before they even happen
I thought the punishment usually came
after the crime caps like that's not how
we do it that's not America which leads
to my favorite part in the trailer and
shows that Captain America is like no
I'm idealistic but that doesn't mean I'm
an idiot what we get started does anyone
want to get out
let's see that again one more time
because it's so cool
yeah just kicks that thing up like it's
Marty McFly's skateboard but it's caps
shield and his trailers looking cools
like oh this is awesome and out of
nowhere this crazy awesome badass
looking mask dude's like yeah I'm here
to wreck [ __ ] now he looks pretty
awesome anyone with a mask and long hair
they're going to innately look cool I
have a sneaking suspicion this guy's
actually going to be badass
don't worry that guy causes too many
problems the Avengers will all gather in
that floating fortress and they're gonna
wreck his [ __ ] up guess not oh there is
that well that sucks ass like ASCAP
we'll just have to throw his shield of
his head and end him that way the guy
doesn't kick ass I'm gonna be really sad
at this point if he's not a villain that
would be really cool if he was like some
sort of antihero he's like no no I'm not
a villain Captain America I'm just a
badass soldier on his own way
who knows he has a mask we're not
supposed to know much about him in the
end Captain America the Winter Soldier
looks cool I love the fact that he's
still working with shield and he's like
yeah but shield is and how we do it Nick
Fury's like yeah it is and he's like no
he kicks up his shield he's all like
nice how you do it to the trailer for
Captain America the Winter Soldier have
you seen it what do you think about this
did you like the first Captain America
if you didn't are you looking forward to
this anyway whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
america [ __ ] yeah